Even when a film is deserving of a perfect
5-star rating, it doesn’t mean they’re
flawless.
Directors spend so much time making sure the
larger picture of their movie is cohesive,
that sometimes little things fall through
the cracks.
These may be highly-paid professionals, but
they are human and can let an error or two
slip by into the final cut.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Biggest Movie
Mistakes Hidden in Popular Films.
Ant-Man
In the opening scene, Dr. Pym punches Mitchell
Carson in the face and blood can be seen pouring
out of his nose.
As the scene progresses, we notice that the
blood slowly disappears.
It seems Mitchell was slowly cleaning but
the real mistake can occurs when his close-up
reveals a very clean and white handkerchief!
Jurassic World
Chris Pratt is America’s new favorite leading
man, and his magic even impacts the props
he touches.
When Claire and Owen are hiding from the Indominus
Rex in Jurassic World, Owen rests his rifle
against the driver’s door of an old Jeep.
As the dinosaur searches for its prey, it
places its head on that side of the vehicle
and shakes it around a couple of times.
When Owen looks back around to see if the
coast is clear, the rifle is in the same exact
spot, unmoved.
This is one instance where practical and digital
effects didn’t mesh well to create a seamless
shot.
Mad Max: Fury Road
Yes, even Best Picture candidates have imperfections.
Upon doing an ammunition inventory count,
Toast says that the group has four rounds
left for the SKS rifle, which she calls Big
Boy.
A few moments later, Max fires a single shot
from that same gun, and Toast informs Max
he only has two shots left.
If Toast’s initial count was correct, Max
should have three remaining.
It’s a glaring oversight that creates an
unnecessary inconsistency between two scenes
close together and it could have easily been
avoided with a quick double check.
But nobody said the script was awards worthy,
right?
The Martian
When astronaut Mark Watney is presumed dead
by his crew, they have no choice but to leave
him on Mars so they can escape in time.
But as it turns out, Mark wasn’t alone.
In the shot where the character regains consciousness
after being knocked out, the cameraman is
visible in the reflection of Watney’s space
helmet.
With all the video recordings Watney does
in the film, this guy was probably the unsung
hero of the story, yet didn’t get any recognition.
Either that, or filming reflective surfaces
is a little harder than it looks, even when
Ridley Scott is involved.
There is even a shot a little later that seems
to show the whole crew reflected in his helmet
since there are not other structures or anything
around him, but we’ll let you decide!
Avengers: Age of Ultron
One of the more entertaining sequences in
this superhero sequel is when Earth’s Mightiest
all try to lift Thor’s hammer at a party.
But the God of Thunder’s weapon isn’t
the only magical item in the scene.
After all his friends fail at the game, Thor
picks the hammer up with a drink in his hand.
However, in the very next shot, that same
drink is on the table, even though Thor never
stopped to put it down.
Joss Whedon had a lot to sort through with
this film, but he should have been able to
see this.
Chalk it up to the dangers of splicing takes.
Inside Out
This modern classic was hailed as Pixar’s
glorious return to form, but things got off
to a shaky start – in the very first scenes.
At the beginning of the movie when baby Riley
appears, her mother appears to be wearing
glasses.
However, when the perspective changes to have
Mom visible from Riley’s point of view,
she’s not wearing the glasses.
It’s always possible she took them off in
between shots, but when you’re looking at
your baby daughter for the first time, you’d
want the clearest view you could get.
Something doesn’t add up here.
Furious 7
Fans were disappointed when the character
Hobbs was left out of commission for a majority
of the film’s running time, but there was
good reason.
He was recovering from a variety of injuries.
Elena tells Dom early on that one of those
was a leg broken in two places.
A shot of Hobbs in the hospital bed confirms
this, as he sports a cast on his leg.
But as the film approaches its finale and
Hobbs decides he has to jump into the action,
there’s no cast on his leg and he walks
without a limp.
We think we may have found who can play Wolverine
after Hugh Jackman.
Mission: Impossible – Rogue Nation
During one of this movie’s many thrilling
action bits, Ethan and Benji are involved
in a chase while driving a car.
The filmmakers use this as an opportunity
for a playful gag, when Ethan asks Benji if
he’s wearing his seatbelt before attempting
an insane stunt.
But it probably would have been funnier if
there was some consistency regarding the seatbelt.
Throughout the sequence, Benji’s seatbelt
alternates between on and off, making things
very confusing for the joke.
Perhaps this is why Ethan asked him about
it?
Either way, Benji doesn’t seem to care about
his wellbeing even when his life is in danger.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
The First Order one-ups the old Galactic Empire
with their Starkiller base, a weapon that
can blow up entire star systems instead of
a single planet.
The film reveals that it gets its power from
the planet’s sun, draining all of its energy.
When that happens, everything should go pitch
black, but at the end of the movie, Kylo Ren,
Rey and Finn are all visible in the forest
during their lightsaber duel.
In reality, only man-made light would allow
them to see each other, but that wouldn’t
make for a very cinematic finale.
Sometimes, you have to bend the rules.
Kingsman: The Secret Service
Typos happen even to the best of us, but during
a film production that takes months, there’s
no excuse for things to be spelled incorrectly.
However, Kingsman never got a proofreader
to look over some graphics.
During the news broadcast covering the release
of the free Valentine SIM cards, the headline
spells “worldwide” wrong.
It says that the product will be distributed
“wordlwide” in big letters for all to
see.
Modern media is a mad dash to be the first
to report a story, but it doesn’t help credibility
if there are glaring errors like this.
Those are our picks for mistakes hidden in
popular films.
Are there any we missed?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!